おはようございます
カメラからわかるかな僕髪の毛がー
明るいんですよホラー
めっちゃここらへんとか第袋が出てきたんですけどすっごい明るくて
まああるいは嫌なんですよにゃんキーみたいに思われるしたここ日本には買うだけ
当たる人はこう
ヤンキーみたいななんかそういう康くん主がまだ残ってると思うんですよ僕がそれを
打破しようと思ったんですけどちょっと目の力不足でとりあえず
もの紙だけを落ち着いた色にしたいと思ったんですけど
儲かるだけが傷みすぎてよも入らないと
カラーリングしても一日で取れたんですよ
どうしようと思ったんですけど
そこでですよ
あの
フォーレさーんとかよくマニックパニックっていう神消すなんか色入れる
ヘッダーの使ってるんですけど
これです
でかい
いうとん
何度か何とか何とかすみませんカラートリートメントっていうんです
ここはブラウンというのを買いましたが2800円したんですけど
すっ
まあ
あれですよ
髪の毛を傷まずに色を入れるっていう
やったんですけど
使い方は全くわからないんですよ
さあいきます
手袋あってべくの電話という句のない手袋ない手袋ないよ
なんか片方しかないというところであります
つけて20分放置ということですさっそくやっていきましょう
ん
ああいいん純するあんまりへ
こんなんですあ
ごめんなさい落ちてましたここに
おっ
はーはっはー
ほぼん頬ほおお
ん
あっ
じゃあちょっと落としていきます
こんな感じになりましたーーー
どうですか
なあ
以外た成功じゃないですかそんなに黒くないし
さりげない遺産平内茶色とはまさに
this is it ですよディズ1頭
というわけどうですかこのかねえな
ここはここのブラウンあと前と比べてだいぶ
暗くなったんですけど今さりげなく茶色がまた校
さらにこれトリートメント効果も留守来て神時がすっごいでるんでる
さらさらするんですよ
なんで髪の毛痛まずに
色を変えるって事なんで
ぜひあの
髪の毛が明るくて広いたんで色が入らなくて困ってるとか言う人
糸末に髪の毛を染めれますから
この演じるつからトリートメントこのトリートメントぜひ使ってください
ザーンって
ni